der wahlkampf wird inzwischen nämlich
mit allen mitteln geführt und jetzt
werden auch kinder eingeschaltet sie
interviewen die kandidaten wie wir
später noch sehen werden und beraten
jetzt auch ihre großeltern bei der
wahlentscheidung wir schauen da mal rein
gut sagt man habe ich ein gewinner steht
und ich habe ich ein kleines an diesem
tag mein name ist ja ich bin hier um
euch zu sagen dass
europa die klimakrise stoppen können und
das tun die einzige hoffnung ist dass
sie es auch wirklich tun im september
ist bundestagswahl und das ist sowas wie
unsere letzte chance die klimakrise mit
politischen maßnahmen
aufzuhalten unsere jetzige
bundesregierung hat in den letzten 16
jahren leider viel zu wenig unternommen
um kommende generation sowie dich vor
den gefahren der klimakrise zu schützen
und deshalb wie enthalten mit dieser
wahl ob wir die klimakrise angehen oder
nicht das problem ist nur die jungen
menschen die genau auf die straße aber
junge leute entscheiden keine wahl die
bis 30 jährigen machen nur 15 prozent
der stimmen aus wie quasi wahlberechtigt
sind bei der bundestagswahl machen
unsere großeltern fast 40 prozent der
berechtigten stimmen aus gern die wählen
sehr gerne und sehr oft ein
weiter so der politik
summa summarum wir brauchen eure
großeltern enkelkinder brief it.de das
ist eine seite wir haben freunde von ihr
ins leben gerufen wir setzen dabei auf
das älteste kommunikationsmittel der
menschheit
den da gibts sowas wie einen briefroman
und wer hilft euch dabei an sehr guten
pointierten und
argument haltigen brief aufzusetzen du
schreibst du brief an seine oma an
seinen opa und bitte sie
die richtigen worte und argumente
findest du auf enkelkinder brief de nach
jetzt mit unterstützt die initiative und
vielleicht haben wir die chance bei der
wahl etwas zu bewirken ich sage vielen
dank für eure aufmerksamkeit und auf
wieder also oma und opa haben offenbar
keine ahnung wo sie ihr kreuzchen machen
sollen brauchen die unterstützung der
enkelkinder bei uns im studio ist nina
schenk aus unserer wirtschaftsredaktion
bestseller-autorin morgen
ein clip der dich ganz besonders aufregt
ich frage mich wo bleibt der aufschrei
also man kennt das ja von anderen videos
wo künstlern was gemacht haben wie alles
dichtmachen damals von jan josef liefers
da hab ich nicht gegen aufgeschrieben
habe aber viele gemacht ist immer
wichtig sich mit sachen
auseinanderzusetzen wo bleibt hier der
aufschrei ich meine dieses video zeigt
ja wie wenig demut wir von den alten in
unserer gesellschaft haben also annette
frier die stört mich ganz besonders sie
sollten sich schämen für das was sie da
gesagt hat die großeltern wen ein weiter
so ihr müsst das jetzt umdrehen das
heißt unsere großeltern wir haben
überhaupt keine demut maddie kann man
sich sowieso in unserer gesellschaft
alles was die alten machen ist sowieso
blöd alte weiße männer demut für alte
fehlanzeige aber das setzt dem ganzen
doch jetzt die krönung auf und man muss
es auch mal ganz kurz einordnen also was
sie da sagen wenn man das sieht dann
denkt man ja oh gott kurz vor zwölf die
klimakrise wir sind alle am ende also
erstmal hat deutschland vor allem auch
in den vergangen jahrzehnten bei dem
klima kriens ein globales thema wir
haben das pariser klimaabkommen immer
erfüllt und sogar über erfüllt ja also
es ist nicht so als hätte deutschland
die ganzen letzten jahrzehnte gegen
klima gearbeitet natürlich geht da mehr
aber das wollen alle parteien
ich würde sogar sagen ist gar kein
problem wenn eure großeltern auch die
union wenn es für sie das richtige
programm ist und man darf nämlich eine
sache sie niemals vergessen der umwelt
ist es egal welche partei du willst weil
wenn man außer die fdp die fbw aus dem
pariser klimaabkommen austreten alle
anderen parteien wollen drinbleiben
erkennen dass an und wollen es auch
erfüllen und sogar über erfüllen und
dementsprechend was soll das und wo sind
die fakten ich war auf der webseite hat
mir diese briefe angeschaut die
vorgeschrieben sind diese so was von
emotional triefend sind für mich das
wieder gezeigt ja die medien branche ist
anscheinend so links und so grün dass
diese künstler sich nicht schämen kinder
dazu aufzurufen ihre großeltern zu über
nicht nur zu überzeugen sein dass sie
ihre stimme bekommen andererseits
argumentieren ja die schauspieler dort
auch das sozusagen auf diese art und
weise die kinder eine stimme bekommen so
zu sagen wir großeltern kinder nicht
wählen können dann geht es auch um ihre
zukunft ja aber die schauspieler wäre
das jetzt ein video von wegen wir
sollten die wahl stimme ab 16 einführen
das finde ich ist ein sehr legitimes
thema bin ich ehrlich gesagt übrigens
auch für warum nicht schon mit 16 wählen
aber das ist es ja nicht es ist du
solltest die stimme deiner
großunternehmen weil du weißt besser was
gut für deutschland ist als seine
großeltern und ich meine einer t frieren
vor allem die stört mich ganz besonders
in dem video dieses weiter so also auch
die faktenlage so schlimm geht es uns
übrigens auch gar nicht in deutschland
der wird mit emotionen und panikmache
werden unsere kinder instrumentalisiert
ich finde es furchtbar und ich erwarte
hier einen großen ausschreibung mit ich
heute morgen gestartet
[Musik]